hi in one second you'll have the intro
and what you missed before you enjoy the
show please know that it is supported by
viewers like you
I don't say it like PBS where we're
supported by viewers like you but really
grants from the federal government we
are entirely funded by you and mugs were
not monetized right now lotto with
credit com / mug club it's 99 dollars
annually 69 for students veterans active
military you get this hand s mug but you
get a show like this that you enjoin
YouTube on Thursdays every day Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday there's Ash
Wednesday we also have a life advice and
you can send in your video questions or
fan videos artwork at loud orth clatter
calm / ask we really do appreciate the
support and the show doesn't continue
without it funded entirely by you enjoy
the show a rumor that you are obviously
a man of your well off a man of means
that you exclusively put your cigars and
carry them into the most the most
opulent beautiful cigar lounges in a
Tupperware container there any truth to
this truth oh I'm enlightened you son of
a [ __ ] but if you feel that it's a sin
or you feel convicted that it's wrong it
means for you that is the case so if you
think your pecker is small it must be
really bad
[Music]
yes
[Music]
lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
Oh Steve Crowder is a gross person I
mean that even Crowder I mean this is
what you can expect from crap like
YouTube practice feet before taking any
action against conservative commentators
steven crowder who is that steven
crowder steven crowder is youtube's
ideal creator he makes cheap long
content that tons of people walk on
substances are really funny so that's on
that you know what you can do with your
copyright strikes and if you ain't way
enough to do it yourself
I'd be happy to oblige I really would
going on this shows and say all kind of
things but I don't
from where I am the sun is shining
here at entertain anyone who don't like
it can get bone
[Music]
Thank You steven crowder from where I am
sun is shining
here entertained
and it will like it can get bone
but if you a Stephen promise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's called the teacup ride if anyone's
ever plated it Disney will need to spin
the table mercy of your babysitter later
did hard time you were failing at hula
hooping that's mainly because I'm very
white know who can name the reference to
the intro you get a free t-shirt because
my half asian lawyer didn't know one
meal was nominated for the Academy Award
I'm sorry I was in a prison Jon Voight
Dustin Hoffman I haven't introduced you
yet question of the day before we get to
Gavin McGinnis we'll be on the show I
don't just want to know why you think
Donald Trump will win in 2020 I want to
know
think of where you were this time last
year are you more or less confident that
he'll win why let me know I really want
to see that progression for me now if
I'm not a Vegas oddsmaker but I would
say plus 19,000 I think it's as close to
a sure bet as you can get in politics a
half Asian lawyer bill Richman is here
are you sir
great glad to be quarterblack keratea
way too cute natty and he's on vacation
so we have Gerald be here today
Gerald see Gerald be unfortunately had
an accident with the safety traveling
the house but I love Gerald see he does
a great lamprey Josie do your lamprey
[Laughter]
the Great Lakes that made its way with
the zebra mussel right through Lake
Champlain Bernie we're looking at you to
see the lamprey one more time Wow
Olympia goes a lot to get to will be
talking about the debates we'll be
talking about why Donald Trump will win
in 2020 Kevin McGinnis but first Donald
Trump May Day is a pilgrimage to India
and let's watch Indians for macho man
Trump
[Music]
I will never write anything as good as
macho man earlier people don't may not
knows early reports they had indicated
that dumb Donald Trump walked to the
stage really with the village people's
macho man but you guys these were the
early stories but it turned out it was a
mixup a song was actually for the
evenings emcee an opening act famous
Bollywood celebrity impersonator macho
Iman Randeep savage it is grossly
offensive on so many levels it was a big
thing
Indian did roll out the red carpet for
President Trump Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi shouted namaste Trump to
the crowd which repeated it back to a
very happy Donald Trump however once the
president realized the streets were
littered with human fecal matter he said
Nemus stay at the Embassy okay I thought
it was in India not San Francisco I have
no idea it's the same thing but there's
an app for it do you know that there's
an app in San Francisco
rather than cleaning up the human [ __ ]
they say let's [ __ ] well there's people
in Silicon Valley between urinating on
the Redwoods and then worshipping Molech
they can figure out an app so that we
can avoid stepping on the human feces
you know what that's not the entry point
to the problem solution this is the peak
Silicon Valley right there this is
Silicon Valley also in the news things
that we don't like
speaking of Mike Bloomberg he's been
getting panned obviously for the debate
performance Tuesday night especially
over just some of the horrendous
attempts at jokes well I think what's
right for New York City isn't
necessarily right to tell the other
cities otherwise you'd have a naked
cowboy in every city and it only gets
more awkward because he paused right
like right right and no one laughs much
like this program here
you can't see that we have four people
in the audience it's really just
producers who are I mean they're legally
obligated here that's already filling up
in a union don't show up Friday so well
Bloomberg didn't do is he didn't do as
badly as the last debate some experts do
feel that Michael Bloomberg actually was
um you know he was doing what what did
somebody say Bloomberg three times okay
so a rabbi a priest and a Jew what's
going all right he's got my vote
what what are you doing Mayor Bloomberg
Stephen I'm linking okay no one plank
that's not a thing anymore it's not my
thing is not a thing
okay boomer okay he just works so hard
at it there's an outro to corporations
are people out of the audio booth um our
top story to this week or one of them is
Harvey Weinstein he was indicted yeah
and could face life in prison two counts
of predatory sexual assault one count of
criminal sexual act in the first degree
this is big a lot of people are talking
about it here is actually a clip from
his sentencing I want to start by
thanking Harvey Weinstein for organizing
this amazing day
this is possible because of Harvey he is
a wonderful human being a good friend
and just a powerhouse and the fact that
he and his team took the time to make
this happen for all of you should say
something not about me or about this
place but about you mmm that should say
a lot yeah Oh missus photo- uh Sigourney
Weaver you may know him mr. Weinstein is
a convicted rapist a ruthless misogynist
merciless producer one of the most
cutthroat industries in the world but I
know him as my friend Harvey
inappropriate it's the children's book
if I ever heard one
I think it bothers me what the wine is
now everyone talks a bit like oh yeah
Harvey was the open guy I totally hit it
up E right yeah we have Whoopi we have
Blake Lively we have Michelle Obama
there's someone else in there I don't
know who it is like no one just says
like yeah I just screwed him and I got
an Oscar right hey I do wonder too if
this this secret now in Hollywood
considering you see what's been coming
out if the the Harvey Weinstein secret
now is is the pedophilia going on home
I'm not saying it's some ring of
Illuminati but it is something that is
abnormally common in the industry
compared to the general population I bet
you in five years we'll be talking about
it we all knew we all know yeah it
wasn't news to us so anyway every one
every one of those is a thing we're new
about it and it's an open secret people
are drunk I mean the fact that people
have been joking about some of these
things for decades just like with
Michael Jackson right everyone's joking
about it and yet now it actually
happened I think it was that he had like
a couple of good songs yeah it's just
like they're it's like they're they're
just rats everywhere better Hollywood
who would have thought he'll know the
guy who did Elmo he's not even on camera
and it went to his head it went to his
head he had groupies he was a puppeteer
for Elmo and then there was that
documentary in the Dark Crystal for
those who don't know the guy who played
Elmo
untoward relationships with younger men
he was booted on ceremoniously after
they did this whole documentary on
networks to be moseying there's a
documentary in the Dark Crystal the
making of it's unbelievable you see how
they build up all these sets in these
puppets and I'm watching it now go a
pause buzz and then I try to digital
zoom when I realize I can't do it
because not everything's a touchscreen
you ever do that with your TV like I'm
just in it
Blade Runner I've never done the way I
expect from you Vizio so it's the ELMO
guy at dirt crystal all right the
international news Mexico but Mexico
they have a 22 foot statue of baby Jesus
that Lou he'll just like Phil Collins it
also might be the biggest sculpture
sculpture of baby Jesus in the world
yeah look at that thing this is
obviously this a lot of people have been
offended and it is ridiculous everyone
knows that Christ looked like Peter
Gabriel
[Music]
it's uncanny Hema he walks amongst us
yeah and of course by the way should
also be clear in the spirit of fairness
black Hebrew Israelites they actually
they have a claim that Jesus looks
strikingly like Teddy Pendergrass he's
the son of soul funk we share so lucky
that's B's you know what I see it too
yeah can't we just acknowledge it by
people who aren't talented when it comes
to music
I mean honestly there is a genetic
component that black people when you
meet a black person you can't say oh
[Laughter]
yeah knew it it's totally happening
that's not racist right because it's a
compliment compliment him on his story
this next door I just said the actor
known for portraying human McGruff the
Crime Dog he got 16 years 16 years in
prison on drugs and weapons charges and
then of course he's best known for the
tag line take a bite out of crime it's
it's sad it's the saddest news actually
for a child PSA characters since Smokey
the Bear was indicted on charges of
child pornography and that one was
really hard come on usually don't hear
the audience here like there are four
people but I'm pretty sure you guys
could hear I'm offended I shouldn't be
in this room I shouldn't be here but Vox
made it so drew it's not for Vox I would
have absolutely been banned true they
only made it stronger
Thank You Vox speaking of animals by the
way um the at the Santa is at Santa
Anita was an insane I need a horse
racetrack three horses have died in
three days this comes from HuffPo on top
of the dozens that have died since 2019
these three deaths have been drawing
scrutiny from government official
and animal rights activists suspicious
activity sounds like a job for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what tell you doctor Autzen that's
terrible and there were some people here
wondering if we would we would like just
well you're not gonna do the whole
Benedict cumberpatch Yeah right
Sherlock horsing right you've never
watched the show yeah you don't know how
it goes
puts so much work into a play um finally
speaking of Catorce is like oats john
oates horse i know that's a say that was
really good i know lesser of hollow
notes he week and said that he's had sex
with thousands of women at least so many
that he's lost count and he added if you
weren't a rock star during the 70's or
80's you can't comprehend what it was
like sex one thousand really here's the
thing it shouldn't come as a surprise to
anyone who was actually listening got an
edge girl and it's gone so far that I
think I'm gonna get it checked out cuz
when a scratch sit down thanks buddy
it's a [ __ ] girl and it's gone so far
doctor said he's gonna have to have your
team my wiener but it won't give it too
far get you far I really do appreciate
everyone who works with this team and
you know if you guys would be fired
immediately how much does it bother you
and I I think I don't want to pissed you
off here but that you work so hard you
have such a great voice you're so
talented musically he actually he
created that scratch from track you have
we wrote lyrics you sang it and the
whole sketch is just stolen out from
under you by this son of a [ __ ] with a
mustache I'm curious yeah why was Mario
I'm so angry there's a natural rhythm
there you just can't can't fake that
I'm jealous and I'm very sad nothing I
do will ever be as funny as his mandolin
playing whatever but there was a fighter
Anderson Silva we'd always looked like
you would play the mandolin f3o and then
people like I was just like a
pelvic-thrust thing that's just gay so
trivia contest winner by the way before
we move on yeah Simon who is it how come
barbecue at Smokey and Ronnie who
correctly identified we print cold
that's right Otis Otis Ed McMahon check
he has to cash for like four scissors oh
yeah Otis well cultural differences okay
and now it is time to get to the meat
segment
some people call it a dive in segments
but that's because they didn't know what
it was called we called it use that raw
meat in the video yeah I know that did
we actually film that the run I don't
remember no I
oh yeah totally by the way carnivore
diet do you know that you know no more
diet yeah lost eight pounds Wow yeah so
it's official I wanted to give horrible
diet I had to pause because I realize I
said anything more it could be legally
liable yeah I know you try yourself and
showed up but see how the scurvy works
out I think outside of some kind of
catastrophic economic event um I forgot
some ribeye fat from the carnivore yeah
also my pants are just filled to the
brim with diarrhea but it's a system
that your body's it's a system that your
body's purging did you know that other
people do it's like essential oils
cleanses and then they do some radical
diet you're like oh I don't know I'm I'm
vomiting and you got diarrhea all over
the walls uncontrollably
it's my master bedroom it looks like a
sunburst pattern it was a white wall
there's like that's just your body
detoxifying yeah detoxifying what
whatever it was that was before this for
guys like mercury or we don't have a way
to test just keep eating but kidneys or
when you were eating vegetables and
fruits right the bodies like purge purge
this purge the green so I do think that
Donald Trump is going to win 2020
I feel that I can declaratively state
that at this point but let me tell you
kind of why and I do want to know what
you think out there what you guys okay
before we move on you have to place a
bet what chances do you place on Donald
Trump winning 2020 first you have Asian
100 really yep you feel that confident
yep
you did say 100 percent did it gets
impeached in the house and you were
correct yeah let's be honest that wasn't
really a gamble nope
neither is this I mean at this point a
hundred percent like yeah they look
ridiculous
I'm gonna head revenge you get into your
[ __ ] I'm gonna beat you move a sketch
ma you don't like Brazil
okay what do you think there are audio
wait I don't know how betting works but
I don't think 100% is waiting Rhenish
but I do think he's gonna win - and I
wanna know what you focusing out there M
or you what about Darryl interviewer
yeah he really is appreciate dedication
to craft
it's a one-trick pony but that one trick
maybe you can't put a price on she only
had one move worked for so long yeah you
can't put a price on on vibe right you
know when we hire do the golden ticket
what he adds to the room it's intangible
it can't be quantified but every time
when I'm feeling a bad day I just I look
I look and I get this I get him just
those eyes looking back and I know he
loves me I can tell so couple of things
right I'm definitely more confident than
at this point last year I wouldn't say a
hundred percent because I don't want to
be embarrassed but you guys apparently
have a problem with it Thank You Hall
but I'm more confident because things
have changed I used to say that Bernie
would be the hardest candidate for
Donald Trump to beat I thought Elizabeth
Warren would be the easiest I still
think that remains true but I think that
Bernie Sanders is actually far easier to
beat than he would have been this time
last year which we'll get to in a second
but really I want to be very clear here
don't get complacent folks because now
you have some people out there saying
for example all these people in this
studio saying a hundred percent they're
lying they're just not honest people
my point is because bill doesn't get to
vote three million times it's still only
one vote so you need to go out and vote
don't even know this but thus far here's
the first point as to why I think Donald
Trump will be president in 2020 and
you've heard me be critical of him when
I think it's necessary I'm not a
cheerleader I've talked about when I
think he he runs the risk of losing thus
far the Democrats the debates it's just
been an absolute mess
talk about minimum wage anyway to the
question we disability millions of Judah
Liam pop affordable housing
[Music]
[Applause]
look that looks like a pre-fight press
conference kind of guy who would have
gray hairs well life and then walk into
the office with completely blonde hair
one day and be mad at you if you noticed
yeah what are you talking about what why
you pay such attention my hair
homophobia they've done something
remarkable Democrats it's a miracle
they've made president Trump seem sane
and like the only adult in the room man
this is like we need some reason here
can someone bring in President Trump and
that's just not me as a conservative
that's what people are saying everyone
widely acknowledges these as an absolute
dumpster fire here's another point where
I think that'll trouble be President you
have the Bernie the Bernie Sanders this
schism schism or schism he's good schism
I just wanted to give audio wait a
chance because he gets mad at me if he
doesn't chime anything like okay we get
it superstar so I do say that get some
get some swivel hips you'll get more air
time we only reward me right here
lampreys in Sweden Oh quarterback here
we're going to now you're going to be
swiveling your hips in every sketch we
can find I'm okay with it that was now
you sounded Mexican yeah that's what we
thought you spoke Spanish for years so
the only frontrunner we have right now
is burning okay
let's talk about this kind of schism he
caused he's caused this massive rift in
the Democratic Party okay so you have a
step you have these other Democrats or
they call them al establishment
Democrats as that used to be known all
non Bernie Democrats and then you have
Talking Heads who are basically saying
that Bernie Sanders who's the front
runner is a stooge a Nazi he's a he's a
tool for Putin
but basically pretty similar to
everything that they threw at Donald
Trump the happiest person right now it's
about
115 moscow time this thing is going very
well for Vladimir Putin I promise you
he's probably staying up watching us
right now
it's helping him have plans to help and
run the primary what I was at Bernie
Sanders wins I'm pretty sure he has a
lot to say about billionaires no one but
Bernie Stephanie come on he's an
anarchist he would love to burn down the
United States I'm reading last night
about the fall of France in the summer
of 1940 and the general right now calls
up Churchill and says it's over do they
want Bernie Sanders to take over the
Democratic Party in perpetuity well I
mean he said over he sets the direction
for the future the party maybe they'd
rather wait four years and put it in the
Democrat that they like Chris Matthews
always seems surprised that he has that
job it's a Christmas that's the camera
light which is remarkable they've really
become the party of old white guys with
the exception of club pitcher who's
really honestly the only one who seems
like an adult I know people don't like
her i watch her neck today on she's
young
yes I'm saying with the exception of
Clevenger i actually thought she handled
herself pretty well so you have them
going after Bernie this way and I do
think that some of those
characterizations are unfair he's he's
not a Nazi he's a pinko commie
and I mean that seriously I mean that
absolutely seriously think was a boom er
and they're talking about some relative
who would say I think he's a communist
that guy in his mind was picturing
Bernice and oh yes right he's an actual
he Woo's honeymoon at the USSR who does
that Bernie
Turks and Caicos Barbados ah let's go to
Latvia I don't know I know a lot of you
isn't but I don't know all the USSR
Russia out there it sucks it's a crappy
country with people I don't respect on
the other side you have entire
nationality of people no respect that's
you have it's okay they're white so you
have Bernie on the flip side and all the
supporters right and I understand the
pushback but this is what's imply it's
only going to get worse I think for the
Democrats at least for the time being
until they narrow this down or they
accuse all non Bernie supporters of
being establishment and centrist or just
flat-out evil billionaire elitist that's
their attack as you may have noticed
lately the establishments getting a
little bit nervous I wanted to go back
to what you said about our Left Party we
don't have a Left Party in the United
States Democratic Party is not a Left
Party she says well literally sitting to
the left of that gentleman he burned his
mouth on a piece about folks were
concerned about his rise and his surge
especially among young voters that this
may be causing some trouble for the
establishment did that concern you at
all well we need to cause trouble for
the establishment because the
establishment is who we're fighting
against it has come up from a candidate
who almost all de stablishment has
pinned their main hopes on and he's
talking about bribing politicians in a
positive way yeah he's saying that racks
talking to Goldman Sachs he didn't have
to repeat it they all already knew
remember Goldman Sachs
what you do with politicians as you
bribed them because it wouldn't want to
talk to people at Goldman Sachs
no that would be absolutely absurd
establishment is just the word of a
threat here's the crazy thing compared
to Donald Trump because I know this has
been talked about with Donald Trump he's
anti-establishment but there's there's
something to it right there's there's
some teeth to it because if you're
anti-establishment as a conservative as
an outsider as a Republican you're
actually trying to some degree tear down
the system you're actually trying to
some degree to shrink the role of the
establishment in DC when Bernie
complains about the establishment it's
because he yearns to be that he wants
that or Bloomberg only talk about the
establishment they want to determine
what sodas you can drink whenever
someone says pro-choice I don't use that
term they're pro-abortion I'm pro-life
they're proportion they're not
pro-choice when it comes to what car you
can drive what kind of soda you can
drink what you can pay in taxes where
you can send your charitable donations
are not pro-choice in any other facet
outside of ending the
life of another human being inside your
stomach right they're not pro-choice at
all it's remarkable to me they're anti
howdy how can you be anti-establishment
just like Rage Against the Machine when
they campaign for Obama
yeah you raid against the machine by
endorsing it except for this machine I
mean the reality is and this is the
thing that I think that some of the
Democratic candidates and even in the
even amongst the mainstream Democratic
voters they're realizing it's just
Bernie trying to come on top of the
establishment he doesn't want to tear
down the end of us he actually wants to
make more of an establishment through
bigger government programs and
everyone's going wait a minute I don't
under
the establishment but it's just you want
to run it that's right that's what the
changes and I think so going back to the
point on Bernie I used to think Bernie
would be tough why let me take explain
to you and this was a lot if you go back
and watch the the segments I thought
okay Hillary Clinton lost a lot of
states that surprised me for example
Michigan I think Bernie does well in
those states because of the unions right
it's it's it's easy to appeal to unions
as a socialist or more a lot of the
union's just believe that Hillary
Clinton was an elitist and the same
thing with Michael Bloomberg right I
don't think that Michael Bloomberg has
any chance of winning the Rust Belt I
think Bernie has a better choice or at
least I thought he would have had a
better choice to wing the Rust Belt
against Donald Trump and that's kind of
what he needs to win this election
here's the thing though now we've
reached a different point he's a
socialist revolutionary right
self-described well the revolution means
a 180 change in direction it means
you've got to change everything because
nothing's working but ninety percent of
Americans don't want that right now
ninety percent of Americans are
satisfied with their own personal
finances things are getting better for
the average American a lot better the
tax cuts they reduced in cut the income
tax bill for by the way not just a super
wealthy the median income households by
nearly 60% record low unemployment also
layoffs also high job participation rate
we have increases in household income
wage growth record-breaking stock market
on top of that we have people who are
finally take note of how good the
economy is according to a poll because
Mr Sanders is almost entirely determined
by polls if you look at his policies
usually well if you look at 80% support
90% of the of the day that's a lot of
people it's like almost all we
understand Bernie that you had a bad
high school experience and
you want some friends all right we get
it just like the guy who shows up to a
party with an acoustic guitar plus
puff-puff pass you're Peter that's my
point okay but here's the thing the
Trump economy right now he actually has
the highest economic approval rating of
any president in the last 20 years
overall approval right now that's gonna
be 9% yeah his overall approval rating
and if he compares disapproval way
better than Barack Obama at this point
in his presidency so it's really hard I
don't know what the argument is and this
is why you see that letter that was
being circulated from from Nancy Pelosi
if you were saying I'm a socialist
revolutionary I need to change this
system that would make sense after the
economic collapse right right now when
you're going back to the stock market
crash in 2008 okay absolutely
it doesn't really make sense that we're
gonna tear this whole system down and
start anew
when it's better than it's ever been
according to 90% of Americans I think
Bernie Sanders is far less appealing
right now and the numbers should startle
them do you think they'll see this yeah
Americans aren't stupid they're not
gonna they're not gonna see these
numbers and think we need something
different yeah right right they
recognize the consequences right we're
seeing it's when it's when he's pushed
for the details that's when everyone
goes well but I don't know that we can
afford an X number of friends of
trillions of dollars because I feel like
that's not gonna change things in a way
that we really want it to change right
and instead of saying you know look I
mean there's something to be said about
I believe that the changes need to
happen some of the more centrist
candidates who say hey I'm gonna I'm
gonna make these changes because I think
we're gonna do a little bit of a degree
change instead of someone who says they
want to turn the boat around but really
they just want to be the captain right
and I think it's important to note by
the way this has been a boat turnaround
so do you want to talk about the radical
change the radical at well first off
let's go back through history the
radical idea was this idea of a free
society of free enterprise
we didn't want oil tea we didn't want
what effectively developed into what we
now know as European socialism I know
that didn't exist back in the day but we
were talking about an oppressive
government who had too much control of
people's lives this country was a great
experiment in that we said government
limited the role I've described this
before it's like a hockey referee right
you keep the pace of the game make sure
the players are safe otherwise you keep
your mouthpiece in period you keep your
ear mouthpiece your whistle I was like
what's the word my wienie whistle the
whistle the rake whistle in hockey
keep it in your pocket in other words
you do not overly invade people's lives
you don't call fouls or you don't call
penalties that have nothing to do with
the action around the puck if someone's
not hurting anybody that's not the role
of the government right it's a very
libertarian stance that is the role of
the government then we had Barack Obama
and by the way not just Barack Obama you
could also toss george w bush in there
and you could toss Bill Clinton in there
they were all pretty big government
Republicans I have to acknowledge that I
think a lot of people do and then Donald
Trump campaign on reversing that course
and here's the thing before Donald Trump
I was worried that you would never have
any other conservatives and now we see
generation Z is going to be the most
conservative generation ever why we had
a lot of people baby boomers right if
people look at boomers now and become
okay boomer which is so disrespectful
it's like really really you're texting
that from the phone who would that it
was created by boomers you asked okay
boomer you mean like Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates you ungrateful little pissant so
well Bernie is actually older than a
Boomer that's why they're right I guess
people say to him okay greatest
generation of all time but not you
though so I think it's important to note
like baby boomers were really really
liberal everyone's putting the Daisy
right now in the rifle they were flower
power and then what happened they
experienced Jimmy Carter and then they
experienced Ronald Reagan so they had
contrast and then they became more
conservative when they got older and I
was always concerned when I grew up I
was saying man we don't really have that
in our lifetime we have Bill Clinton and
George W Bush there's not really that
strong of a contrast and then we had
Barack Obama that was a continuation of
that and yeah he's definitely more
charismatic so I thought young people
since they don't have the contrast of
conservatism versus leftism they're not
going to naturally revert back to being
conservative as they get older like baby
boomers did all that's required for
people to be more conservative as they
age is that they witness it put up until
Donald Trump no one had witnessed it or
anything even close to it but here's the
thing when Bernie Sanders talks about
being a revolutionary no the
revolutionary sort of about-face the
change was Donald Trump going in and
it's what they [ __ ] about the slashing
of regulations the slashing of taxes for
people across the board this is very new
for people who might be in their early
20s entering the workforce we're now
even if they're liberal they they have
this as a baseline and then what happens
if there's another Barack Obama or
another Bernie Sanders who admitted that
anyone making over 29,000 is going to
see a drastic increase in taxes go back
to our segment on that with universal
health care Medicare for all
so if you have a 22 year old liberal
today who thinks that he likes Bernie
Sanders but he's getting X amount in his
paycheck then Bernie becomes president
and it's X minus 20 percent 10 percent
guess what you've made a conservative
for life right so I think it's important
to realize that the rock against Bush no
FX Rage Against the Machine they are
again they are the Machine Bernie
Sanders is offering nothing new and the
good thing here is that it's going to
create more conservatives in this
generation than I think we've ever seen
and now since the polls aren't good for
Bernie and they're good for Donald Trump
Bernie has decided to not so much focus
on the economy he is determined to make
sure that you know he's going to get do
everything in his power at least you
know promises to get an F rating from
the NRA I have today a d-minus voting
record from the NRA thirty years ago I
likely lost a race for the one seat for
Congress in Vermont because thirty years
ago I opposed I supported a ban on
assault weapons we must be aggressive on
gun safety not be dictated to by the NRA
and I am proud and I have a d-minus
voting record from the NRA if elected
president it will get worse than that
ladies and gentlemen your f president
game change his admission there is he's
saying look what you know about me now
makes you think I'm a d-minus anyone
who's on the fence or in favor of the
Second Amendment but trust me I'm not
telling you how but it's gonna get waves
your rights will be more restricted than
you could even imagine they saw what I'm
telling you right listen listen when I
was go when I was mayor I had a d-minus
from the NRA but that was in Vermont
which is largely homogeneous and white
when I'm president what people have not
taken into account is my blatant racism
as well coming your way and then he
flashes the [ __ ] sign you're like come
on we all know that you're Latin King
sighs he's got the teardrop tattoo by
the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed here on YouTube and
hit all notifications because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
do consider joining mug club I know a
lot of you enjoy the Thursday show we
have shows behind the paywall
every day as a modernist and podcasts
which I've accomplished mug club and of
course there's there's Mark Levin you
have Dave Rubin you know valley Stuckey
you ever a millennial you have Glenn
Beck you have all kinds of people over
there we try to give you your dollars
worth and we're not funded by a foreign
caliphate huh so you know but we'll take
it al Jazeera I know that your Noland is
out you're in the red you're just
hemorrhaging money that Young Turks
investment isn't quite paying off you
two had to step in with their news
initiative but yeah we can do it
we'll even wear the funny hats so here's
something other thing people are
forgetting why do I realize I don't
wanna say he's a good debater but Donald
Trump is a very effective debater yeah
and you have that you have some people
like this who were who are for example
in analogy would be boxers like I would
love that George Foreman on the show I
think he would be one of the best guests
ever George Foreman was criticized for
not being a great boxer it may or may
not be true he was a very effective
boxer a lot even said he would do is he
would use this sort of cross guard he
would go in and use a technique that
kept himself safe that didn't really
look pretty but he knocked everybody out
before ollie
pretty much oh and then he won the
heavyweight championship at 42 so do not
underestimate how effective Donald Trump
can be on the debate stage whoever it is
in watching these debates
I think he'll eat their lunch so for
comparison I want you to look at how
Bernie Sanders reacted to two boos from
the crowd at this week's to be what I
said is what Barack Obama said in terms
of Cuba that Cuba made progress on
education yes I think really he's almost
like Chris Matthews yes will you crazy
old coot he's so shocked cuz eyes wide
it's amazing people if you think I'm
cutting it out of context go watch the
whole debate it's actually worse than I
can show you he just he just goes really
really and then moves on its merry way
yeah we don't have the time but what I'm
saying is the Castro
cigars and a fashion sense it might as
well be that here's nothing to offer or
justify here's a good rule whether it's
Hitler whether it's Castro whether it's
Stalin even if you think they had some
really tasty threads just avoid any
friends yeah but so do do it don't do it
and by the way it's not like it's not
like political correctness it's not like
we're walking backwards setting
landmines yeah you just you said that
you created a landmine from scratch you
created your own pipe bomb put it down
and this looks like a good place to step
you give this to your cell tactical
mistake you don't have to do that Bernie
you don't have to praise communists he's
being honest he's been true to his own
heart his heart is red commie yeah but
it brings back memories from his
honeymoon yeah so so that was him
responding to booze right
he backed backed up that's also
important to all these guys when they
were getting booze and how do you think
Bloomberg stacked the audience that is
some people have talked about it's
legitimate the tickets were really
expensive one point Bloomberg said he I
don't know who said I saw this he goes I
really respect everyone who stepped in
this debate after I beat you all the
last time and even then the audience he
paid for was like jab and move let's try
and get up on points you're not gonna be
getting a knockout punch tonight mr.
shingles face music that's him reacting
to booze now let's compare this with a
stacked audience exactly Donald Trump in
the same scenario this was someone
actually a Bernie fan I think he tweeted
this outside Twitter does Bernie Sanders
need to do this if the booing doesn't
stop and this is the clip let me talk
quiet
[Laughter]
[Music]
his owners and special-interest so
well they just tell you we needed
tickets you can't get them you know who
has the tickets for the I'm talking
about to the television audience donors
special interest the people that are
putting up the money
the RNC told us we have all donors in
the audience and the reason they're not
loving me their money I'm gonna do the
right thing for the American public I
don't want their money I don't need
their money and I'm the only one up here
that can say that yeah yeah he knows the
real audience yeah in the room that's a
very those people there yes that's right
yeah he know the audience when people
watching at home that well that couldn't
have been more embarrassing for Jeb Bush
if Donald Trump rested his scrotum and
testicles on his forehead hey how did
you like to shaft serve shake yes that's
a good point
he knows his audiences at home and this
has changed politics I think a lot of
people just say Oh Donald Trump went
against the establishment no yeah it's
important obviously a lot of these
people have consultants a ground game
has talked about a lot but people talk
about a ground game it's not as
important as it used to be another
ground game one Ted Cruz Iowa great I
think it won Bernie Iowa not mistaken
with Hillary Clinton I know Rick
Santorum won Iowa back in the day when
and then it end up being Mitt Romney so
that's important but guess what with the
internet now everything you say at any
point is the ground game because people
in Iowa will see that people in New
Hampshire will see that and Donald Trump
understood he didn't need to speak to
the moderators he didn't need to speak
to people in the audience he needed to
speak to people at home which is ironic
considering that Bernie fences himself
you know a man of the people and he was
so flustered by these donors there in
the audience booing him you shouldn't
care you shouldn't care about it it
should not be less relevant the people
at home are the ones who matter and this
is what was interesting two replies were
from people on Twitter the response is a
couple of saying holy crap no wonder he
got elected look at all these people
responding on Twitter so for a lot of
these folks this is another reason I
think that Donald Trump is going to win
this is the first time in three years
they've actually watched Trump in a
debate instead of a clip that CNN has
sliced and diced to make them look bad
right this is
these disasters that are democratic
debates are forcing Americans who are
not necessarily pro Trump to go alright
okay I'm not getting any of this let me
see what Donald Trump has to say as
opposed to playing that game of
telephone with Don Lemon saying what
Donald Trump has to say and you see the
reaction there and oh my god oh my god
you know what not only is that a good
point this is gonna be really hard to
deal with and most importantly it shows
that President Donald Trump has faced
the exact same situations as you see
with Bernie Sanders and he's handled
them far better you know one thing I
think is really interesting is when you
watch that debating you look at the
number of Bernie fans who are saying oh
this is a tactic but actually listen to
what Trump is saying there he's saying
I'm being attacked by the establishment
who write what these people hear and if
you want to do something different if
you want to see this boat go in a
different direction choose me and now
that he's been president he's made
changes and he's still under attack if
you look at any of the mainstream media
they constantly talk anytime they can
find a Republican to bag on Trump they
put it up there and they want to say
look look even the Republican National
Convention doesn't like the RIC will and
they're built right and so yet you can't
kill by and crappies and they get those
guys out there and they go hey wait a
minute um if you actually want to make a
change instead of making government 10
or 20 times larger but you want
something different
actually Trump is your guy right yeah
that's the person it's just it also does
come you cannot teach backbone
necessarily right and I mean it's also
there's also some unpredictability but
we're talking about fighters some people
you don't know how to read them
necessarily that was another thing go
back to Forman his punches to the body
look the exact same as punch to the head
Muhammad Ali talked about that you go
out there with Donald Trump and maybe
he's gonna debate policy with you maybe
he's gonna go out and talk about his
poll numbers or maybe he's just gonna
stand there and say that you're dead
kill JFK you don't know is it coming
down or is it coming over the top while
you're defending that he's pummeling you
in the mid summer talking about the
economy and now you're talking my wife
she's not even here anymore
yeah yeah whose fault is there but it is
remarkable this is we can see a direct
comparison boos from a stacked crowd
with Bernie boos from a stacked crowd
with Trump it's very rare that before
the actual debate of the two candidates
once they go through the primaries that
you get to see the exact same scenario
for a comparison for a contrast we have
that there and it begs the question why
can Trump just speak through the boos
and not care at the exact same issue
where's Bernie shrinks into his shoot
like Tom Hanks at the end of baked it's
a visual let it sit in you'll go that's
exactly what he did he looks like a kid
in an Old Man suit like Tom Hanks from
big exactly so let's go through the
candidate Roker have to get together
McGinnis Warren let's say any of these
people choose I was he probably not
going to be the candidate Warren Trump
wins why because he just bullrushes her
right she's not gonna walk it back the
closest we have is from an apology from
Trump is with Carly Fiorina yet all I
said was you got a good face she's good
she's got a good face right because he
knew she was gonna go after him yeah
Warren he's not gonna back away from
Pocahontas gonna go away he's only going
to get where she is no Pete but gig no
spine no way he can handle it it's going
to look like a father spanking a child
and you know it I hate to say it looks
like it looked but gig also every time
they turned to him I expect him to
answer with but you're like I don't know
yeah I also don't think he's gay I think
is I think he's the only straight man
who's gay husband is a beard it's on my
chest Club achar she's kind of an
unpredictable one here I think she would
actually probably the hardest candidate
for Trump to beat I don't think it's
like that she's a nominee what we've
done I'll try and do a club with her
just make stuff up that's probably he
would do looks like she's an unknown
the a boat they would hand him off a
research he'd go no I think I'm gonna
say that she's contaminating drinking
water
[Laughter]
what are you I'm winning Mike Bloomberg
I think Mike Bloomberg if he's the
nominee some people think he might I
think he defeats himself listen this guy
this is Midwest poison especially if he
picks Hillary Clinton as a running mate
if people saw Hillary Clinton as an
elitist I don't know how they couldn't
see that with Mike Bloomberg and by the
way he didn't ban big gulps this isn't a
lobby he ban drinks over 16 ounces yeah
what a dick right that is no good and
there's it comes to Bernie okay this is
a
Berni listen we have a socialist
revolutionary who wants to revolutionize
the way we were living in America which
is the best economy that we've had on
record safer no major Wars we're doing
better than ever I think that his whole
pitch is unappealing and he's also
basically a pinko commie who went on his
honeymoon to the USSR and now we know is
fearful of the crowd when you're in town
when you live by polls Oliver does a
majority of Americans want insert his
policy here with no way to pay for it
guess what you die by the polls and
right now Donald Trump is doing well in
the polls and we've seen that Bernie
folds like a cheap suit
if someone boos him because that's where
all of his self-worth is tied up I don't
think he's going to be as popular as he
thinks he's going to be I think it's a
walk-off for Donald Trump barring
something completely unforeseen we have
to go to get McGuiness right now thank
you Gavin
how do you feel about Tanzanian P
berries in your winces I think it's a
too acidic do or lie we rehearse as
these are good people bro no no no no no
no okay general I just wanted to know if
you guys got any black rifle coffee okay
all right I tried the coffee WI and it
was good it's how you want to hear okay
I love the perfect medium roast the
subtle notes of caramel with a bit of
toffee on the after palate the Saskatoon
berry with a sliver of almond that comes
through like marzipan I loved every
second of it
and you probably want to judge me for
that right you probably feel like you're
superior but look at you
your plaid shirt your age denim jacket
that you probably paid to have done by
some kid in a sweat shop between shifts
at Apple your horn-rimmed glasses face
it you self-loathing hipster you are
just like nah I am nothing like you
Wilson I will say a lot of in stock next
week okay bring your punch card black
rifle coffee black rifle coffee calms
that was heavy I just jammed my finger
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder
for 20% off your first order
listen there veteran owned company they
do a lot for and with veterans but what
matters to you is do they make good
coffee do they sell yeah listen they
really do it's fantastic I'm a coffee
nerd we're going to have some tutorials
coming up here pretty soon and we're
also here's one thing we double ordered
accidental we have an auto or every
month for this office we go like 15
pounds of coffee a month but we
accidentally set it up so every week
we're getting one or every four week the
point is doesn't matter we're gonna give
away this five-pound bag comment below
why you deserve this five-pound bag of
black rifle coffee this is the this is
the beyond black I think that's the
really dark
also I don't really love dark Rosa do
you hear the thud of that black rival
coffee calm / try to comment below why
you deserve this bag and we will send it
to one lucky fan Crowder County feed and
seed for all your feed and seed needs
and offer my am here with Macho Man
Randy Savage and Randy for what you have
to say to the folks at all oh yeah well
you heard it here folks the gauntlet has
been thrown your move uit
[Music]
mm there's no point in wondering where
your pockets are tasting school
did you say tasty smooth you're an M&M
yeah because that makes that reminds me
our next guest can probably talk about
this we've talked about it before I
believe in Canada there was completely
say mmm frozen burgers beef look at all
the football game stuff they were always
essays this mm is confusing because it's
you know still in the same vertical it's
a food item in mmm you think they have
some time yeah you'd think they have
some kind of monopoly on it and then the
hip hop came and messed it all up so we
had to worry about when you're doing it
phonetically so that's a spoiler for
people who don't know horn X guys he's
also from the great white north or at
least he's a dual citizenship or not but
today he wanted us to plug justice for
liberty comm which we will get to in a
second of course he's the host of get
off my lawn on censored TV Gavin
McGinnis how are you sir I'm good how
you doing I'm doing well you so you
remember the mmm foodstuffs M&M meat
shops was started by charles rennie
mackintosh
and his son Doug Macintosh and they
called it Macintosh and Macintosh since
then was back in Mac and then it was M&M
and it was premium quality meats used in
meat pies use for mints and caddies and
the cows came from Calgary cowboy
country Wow well there you go so that's
I wasn't I wasn't wrong they're very
very good quality and now I'm forced to
just basically pick up the refuse from
Costco so they're selling burgers are
certain bass a booger sirloin burger is
so delicious hey Gavin Senor McGuinness
where where are you right now
I'm at the Gaylord Convention where I
feel most comfortable and this is this
is where no they just let you know the
maturity level of this room all giggle
that's Gaylord it never it never won't
be funny it's like farts
now what's at the Gaylord convention so
it's a Gaylord Convention Center
actually I got a Gaylord convention yeah
there's a difference well it actually is
really ultimately but it's the its CPAC
and they denied my press pass so I paid
600 bucks for me and Ryan to come here
as mere mortals and we'll see if I get
kicked out but I'm not here to pick a
fight I'm here for unity in love and if
I get you're not able to be a kick-out
no no you're not gonna do think we just
put like a camera to face Blake hey
you're a prick and they kicked you I go
wow yeah like Tim Heidecker and
what's-his-name the black guy who went
down - oh yeah they went down to the
Republican convention I think at one
point and it was just so lazy yeah was
just like yeah they didn't they put on
like American flag panties and go bluh
bluh bluh bluh we're gay yeah and they
just assumed that everyone was uptight
and they all just went what are you
doing have a seat what's going on yeah
have a beer embarrassing did you get
those shorts in the gift shop yeah
that's a hot selling it's hot selling
item it's basically C packs Tickle Me
Elmo this year well good by the way if
you even if you are invited to see back
you still have to pay $600 your own
travel oh that's why I hosted it for
four years and I yeah I hosted for four
years three years over for I got
violently ill one time and then it just
you know some people like it it was not
for me I think it's been six or seven
years since I've been there well
hopefully you don't get kicked out so
here's here's my question
- speaking of drama have you been
following the debates at like obviously
last night okay good you watched last
night because no one did it wasn't even
trending on Twitter for the first hour
and a half was it but what's really
really bad let me ask you this we've
been asking everyone today Ari how would
you compare what do you think the
chances are of Donald Trump winning in
2020 today versus how you felt the year
ago do you feel more strongly in a
position unless it went from he was
gonna win by a mudslide about a year ago
now he's gonna win by a mega landslide
these dummies have been going on
identity politics and platitudes for so
long that now that they're someone's
asking them to say something of
substance they're lost they're screamin
fools and it was like Deontay Wilder and
Tyson Fury and last night was a brawl in
a parking lot that was broken eardrums
there was people falling backwards
what's the analogy that Deontay Wilder
and Tyson Fury that was a sanctioned
bout on pay-per-view that wasn't a brawl
in a partner are you are you confusing
with bumfights did you order him to
fight yeah that's a different thing
Wilder in Fury was bumfights
it was total anarchy I mean what did you
see that one point where you grabbed him
you just sort of going yeah I know
blood off of him which is weird because
Dyson furious it's a nice guy he's not
like a tight it just seemed a little out
of character but I like him he's a he's
a user brush of frother a brush of fret
the talky Gavin I'm sure Pete booted J
is a great guy I'm sure they're all nice
but you put them in the ring like that
and they just become yes I don't think
people who judge needs to be in the ring
for that though I want to get back to
the debates look I'm actually convinced
that Peter judge Pete but cakes husband
is a beard I think people but cake is
great in that I don't think he's gay
I've been saying it seems like because
he like came out in his 30s have you
seen them kiss it's like I don't know I
don't think he's actually gay well that
happens with a lot of gays they try it
for a few decades and then they go this
is gross they've run out of alternatives
who do you think the nominee will will
be based on the recent debates because
Bernie is obviously the frontrunner
Bloomberg has more money than God it's
it's tough well I think it's Bernie is
going to be the front-runner he's going
to win everyone's hello he's gonna win
everyone's vote but the DNC will rig it
such that it's Warren and Klobuchar and
then they're gonna say something stupid
like who is the President of Mexico and
that will be the end of the DNC just you
know you're not acting inconspicuous
there at the same time every time
someone with melanin there's getting
washed by you really what time I've got
a lineup of hot broads waiting to come
right up so oh very nice okay well there
you go I just saw the one lady in the
wheelchair but I'm sure she's hot as
well here do you want it do you want to
do it selfie while I'm on Crowder
yeah go ahead let the lady do a selfie
yeah your selfie that way we can see oh
look at that we found Waldo
oh it's in American that's adorable
oh well good that's a lot of fun now I'm
sorry ladies but I have to borrow Gavin
for a minute because he was scheduled a
week in advance if
can you leave it bring it back to Gavin
TV Gavin compliment their physiques and
then move on nice I feel like you're my
Rupert's right now I just wanna send you
through and make you say things that are
very uncomfortable for you but I know
it's very you'll be very quick to be
kicked out what was your favorite moment
from the debates there this last week it
was there were a lot of them oh I liked
when a Biden said that he wrote a bill
that he didn't write and they went
arguing about fact checks or wasn't
there a part when booty gig and who was
it was it
Bloomberg where they were just talking
at the same time yeah like 40 seconds
yes yeah and then Biden jumped in and
said let me finish when he wasn't even
talking
[Laughter]
but kg and I we talked about yesterday
Oh bleep please no then Biden said let
me finish he hadn't spoken for a minute
a half some people thought I was joking
yesterday I think he might actually have
early I mention I think you're right
stuff about did you see that nine hours
story he told the other day about some
guy with a switchblade who was gonna cut
him so he put a chain around his fist
and they met in the parking lot kind of
love Joe Biden pretty really yeah this
story he was a lifeguard in some
dangerous neighborhood and he told
kicked out some dude who then got a
straight razor I was gonna meet him the
parking lot and so he wrapped a chain
around his fist and he said I apologize
for the first part but I don't apologize
for kicking out of the pool it's like a
nine minute story only Vice President
Joe Biden would tell a story to try and
gain him gain some territory the good
graces of blacks and talk about being a
lifeguard Jove I couldn't be more out of
touch like he thinks they can hit like
oh yeah man I hate my life guard too
[Laughter]
life guard they give me all the flack
for my floaties man it's a problem yeah
it would be fun if it were if it were
Biden I think the issue with with Bernie
is that we talked about this yesterday
and just earlier today as well you know
he's a socialist sort of a revolutionary
but he's talking about how the system is
broken 90% of Americans right now this
is the highest ever in our lifetime are
happy with their personal lives they're
also it's also a decade high I believe
as far as their satisfaction with the
handling of the economy so it's tough to
revolutionize to do a 180 on the economy
when everyone is happy with it and so I
used to think Bernie was the hardest
candidate to be and I think that was
right a year ago because he would do
better in the Rust Belt but now that the
economy's been swimming along the
socialist revolutionary it seems less
appealing yeah it's just really students
with student debt they get excited about
this stuff now and I love how by the way
the system is broken and Bernie's
solution is well more system bigger
government because the government isn't
working properly Fred let's expand right
like I always forget his name burello
who's the rage against machine guy Tom
rate against Tularosa no that's another
the other guy sounding name no it's a I
don't know but he said rate you know
Rage Against the Machine I mean he
actually campaigned for Barack Obama
ya know another option for the DNC is
Bloomberg takes Hillary as his running
mate as his VP right he gets in and then
mysteriously Bloomberg gets depressed
and kills himself yeah well so does Alex
Jones is the second that he hears
Bloomberg and Hillary Clinton on the
ticket
it's just I'm just gonna see his legs
dangling next to his carbon block filter
it's not going to go well it's not as
white Alex Jones I just don't think of a
ticket that is more of a nightmare for
someone like Alex Jones or the Rust Belt
either I think they think they're gonna
win Michigan Bloomberg I don't I don't
understand this go ahead I'm opening for
Alex Jones tonight that sounds like a
joke but it's not where you should be
talking to at the Omni Hotel a free
speech thing okay seminar on free speech
now was it because you send me a shirt
that was
free speech TV it's censored TV for some
reason I thought it was free speech then
it was I got sued by free speech TV oh
so we had to change the name whose free
speech TV suing you that free okay all
right okay so it is censored out TV I
got that right and I wanted to get an
update here this is um some of you want
us to talk about justice for liberty
comm and this is from if I'm not
mistaken was at one of the proud boys
was at John kinsman who is he's been
sentenced to prison how many years in
prison now is he sentenced to four years
four years four years four effectively a
bar fight with aunty five where it was
there was mute doors mutual combat
exactly they ambushed them they said
let's do this probably said okay
beat them up for seventeen seconds and
now max hare and John kinsman are in
prison for four years
John kinsman has three kids three black
kids and he's in prison for being a
member of a hate group so we started
justice for liberty for his baby his
newborn Liberty so they can do stuff
like go visit them they put these guys
right at the Canadian border as kind of
a nephew to the friends and family so
it's now like a 17 hour commute to visit
them and that gets expensive so we want
Liberty to be able to see your dad yeah
and we're raising money and it's true
liberty and justice for liberty calm and
you know this is one thing I do want to
that really bothers me no people always
say this can you stop when you try to
when you try to convince people that
you're not racist can you stop saying
you have black friends it's like a whole
and second not only is that a legitimate
defense but you guys thought it was a
legitimate defense is seen in American
History X in that Edward Norton only
learned the wrong ways of his racism
when he had a black friend in prison so
having a black wife should kind of count
well I wouldn't have brought it up if
you didn't throw him in prison for being
in a hate group I wasn't running around
before he was arrested going oh that's
my friend John that's like what if look
she's told the black sheep knows dreads
look they're mixed that's my friend we
didn't bring it up to the bait said
you're a member of a hate group but you
hate black people you're like I'm
married to them dude they started it
yeah I mean and that's a what were they
what were they I was looking at some of
the charges attempt was an attempted
gang assault I've never
heard of that before because usually
when gangs assault it's not an attempt
they attempted they tend to do a good
job they also got assault with a deadly
weapon and John's deadly weapon was he
happen to have like a pen ice in his
pocket that never came out but because
it was on his person it's a deadly
weapon and Max Hare was max Hare was
kicking them with his boots they made
his boot a deadly weapon relisted is
like Exhibit B yeah it was a totem
kangaroo court and there was a third kid
there Ben kyriakos he was brown
they separated him from the trial so
they could focus on this white power
thing and then when it was time for his
trial they just sort of it it's it's
over forget it you run along home
because they realized it would disturb
their narrative it's a total frame job
right yeah and that's really I mean I
know people who I knew a kid actually
from my old high school who got who got
kicked out for a counterfeiting tickets
to the school talent show and then there
was he was like a mule because you
mentioned the Canadian border carrying
drugs across the American border to
Canada this had been going on for a long
time I think DEA had been tracking it he
only joined in the last two weeks and
then he ended up being one of the fall
guys and he only had a few months in
prison for like a major drug trafficking
ring for years for a bar fight Wow it's
it's completely insane well I appreciate
you trying to do what you can as justice
for Liberty calm and I know the shows
get off my lawn at censored TV we are
gonna go for people watching here on
YouTube if you are not a mug club member
good a lot of credit come /mo club join
up because we're about to go to the web
extended with Gavin McInnes
don't say McGinnis yes one moment
John
[Music]
lies deceit fake news if you're feeling
lost in a world gone man
tune into the Young Turks facts don't
care about your feelings you can google
it it's really easy we accept the facts
on our side no I'm not buying any of
that covering the stories that matter
they definitely don't learn about it in
history classes so we're gonna come back
and show you how exactly where she is
and getting to the facts that count and
we'll give you even more facts
everybody get triggered everybody get
triggered Real Talk real Turks
watch The Young Turks live weekday 6:00
to 8:00 p.m. Eastern if you don't join
mug club Maddie will die on now for The
Adventures of the white privilege boy
[Music]
all right there now Timmy I know you're
a teenager but if I've told you once
I've told you a thousand times you can't
park your vehicle faced into oncoming
traffic come on let's move well gee
officer I'm sure sorry can I just go
back to my car now I want you to follow
my instructions either get down on the
ground or follow me away from the
vehicle what officer can I just get my
PCP now well you know usually I'd say no
but you can make it quick come on get
out of here you white rascal oh boy how
about a free base Oh what people will
they find themselves in next stay tuned
for next week's installment of
adventures of the white privilege boys
[Music]
I'm sorry I got distracted from the
drowning dance this week for two reasons
one
you're just hypnotic how so nice you're
hypnotizing him i hypnotize myself in
the i drowned did you really it's a
power you need to become a therapist and
then I thought I broke this pipe
sometimes people by the way cabin
conditioners are great a web extended
interview for those who are and you
don't listen I have to I do have to say
this please do consider joining up at
mug club we know that there are a lot of
it we can look at the numbers a lot of
people who watch on YouTube and check in
some people rip it we really do
appreciate it that you want to watch the
show if you can afford it six and
analogy if you're a student we can't
keep the show going without it so please
do consider during at mug Club letters
kind of that comes flush mug Club people
often ask me if these are real pipes
they are except this one I don't use it
because it was my grandfather's pipe and
so I was very concerned that I may be
broke it guys her and crunch it'll just
be this was very old Oh a little creaky
but my brother refurbished this and then
I realize it's this old pipe it has what
they call a stinger and if you can see
this in there there's a little you know
I don't think an see the little metal
tip in there and the idea was opposed to
sort of a cool down the smoke before it
went into your mouth is that trying to
zoom in and I'm looking here yes meet me
in the middle there you go called a
stinger focus to the idea was and the
reason I bring this up is not that pipe
technology interests you but it was
supposed to cool down the smoke because
metals generally you know steel is
generally cool yeah but it turned out
people hated them because then what
happened was it created condensation on
the metal and it just made the pipes
even more girly in other words they
didn't know what they were doing with
pipe technology back in there we've
we're gonna figure it out we've advanced
leaps and bounds and pipe technology
right now just go to the weed shops you
can even have little glass pipes that
look like penises so they know what
they're doing that's on their ticket but
you know you see their influence
everywhere big pipe yeah um we do and we
also by the way have an extended
interview with Rudy Giuliani from up
Mayor Rudy Giuliani from last week so I
wanted to talk about something here's
someone paid me a compliment recently
and I really appreciated it regarding
the Giuliani interview and if you've
missed the long form was actually really
lonely 20 minutes behind the pay well
for Mudd Club someone simply only really
brought a lot out of them we talked
about cigars
I talked about his personal relationship
with Trump whether they had feuded if
Donald Trump president Trump never been
mad at him and he said you know what
yeah we get over in three minutes so
here's the thing it was very
enlightening to me and that's how I try
and conduct these interviews I actually
want to learn something from these
people I am blessed to be able to sit
down with some of the biggest most
powerful people who made the greatest
impact in our generation sometimes
whether it's sports whether it's
politics and I consider myself fortunate
but I I think a reason that maybe
sometimes say hey the interview is
different on your show I feel like you
brought something out of them it's
pretty simple when you compare for
example Giuliani was I think it was
Kimmel or Colbert you're just watching
an interview with someone myself I don't
want anything from Rudy Giuliani and I
don't hate him that's it I don't need a
scoop you guys tune in whether there's a
scooper net whether it's Gavin McGinnis
or Rudy Julia you're probably more
people will watch with Gavin McInnes
that's my point some people want the
exclusive I don't and I don't hate him
and I want to say this I think that I
would interview Bernie Sanders better
than Jimmy Kimmel could interview Bernie
Sanders why because I also don't hate
Bernie Sanders and I don't want anything
from him sure I'd make fun of him I hate
some of his ideas but I don't hate the
man and let me kind of I realize what it
is it really bothers me about Bernie
Sanders and again it's not him
personally I have a problem with this
progressive idea the left that and
Bernie really most-most crystallizes
this that money creates morality or
dictates morality and that money makes
the man right for a party the Democratic
Party who claims to be so vehemently
against bigoted generalizations
they sure have no problem doing it with
any Tom Dick or Harry who happens to
have the misfortune of carrying around a
little more pocket change than you and
by necessity they place more emphasis on
on money people like Bernie than most
rich men people who accuse the rich of
being and I understand their corrupt
banks of course I'm against bailouts for
the banks but it also against bailouts
for GM and the UAW I'm against bailouts
across the board not because not because
of the fact that they have more money
than me the banks I'm against it because
it's wrong if you don't run a business
model honestly the taxpayer shouldn't
have to foot the bill
whether you're GM whether you're
American Airlines or goldman sachs
it's not about the dollar amount it's
about what's right and by these people
on the left right now they place more
emphasis on money ironically they don't
realize then rich people because I want
to be really clear but this money does
not change the morality or the character
of somebody my amplifies character and
you know what I don't say Oh Bernie is
standing up and any standing up to the
man no it's easy it's easy there's no
it's a very Bernie's route is very easy
just like any socialist before him and I
don't mean that as some kind of a slight
or a pejorative that's what he calls
himself
you can add Democratic in front of it
but who really cares just because you
take a vote to steal doesn't make it
right the easiest thing in the world is
to campaign on socialism I don't give
them any but I don't give them any
points for that especially in Burlington
Vermont the home of Ben and Jerry for
crying out loud why is it so easy
because working and working in and
appealing to Vice is easy what what vice
am I talking about here usually people
think about working advise to think
about strip clubs I think about bars I
think about drugs what am I talking
about
covetousness whether you're rich or poor
if you are covetous you you not the
other guy with more you are the evil one
regardless of what it is you're coveting
regardless of whether you believe that
their gain is ill-gotten or not you are
the covetous one and I'm not saying that
rich people cannot be covetous bastards
of course they can but so can poor
people so can people like Bernie Sanders
so can people who got Gender Studies
degrees when their friends went into
STEM fields and they want their student
debt to be completely absolved those
people can be covetous too it's not just
rich people and the entire platform of
Bernie Sanders and socialism when you
say it's based on one of the deadly sins
it is it is based on appealing to
covetousness that's the entire key and
just because you have less I want to
drive this home of it it does not mean
that you somehow are given the moral
high ground some of the most despicable
people evil people throughout humanity
we're very poor started off that way if
you look at I don't know I'm the the
Bundys the Dahmer's I'm sure a few of
them are in public housing I don't know
exactly but the point is you can find
evil people regardless of financial
level
and it has nothing to do with your
checking account so you did my challenge
to you I challenge to you is this
because this is something that all of us
need to check myself included myself
included you know what I you know when I
covet sometimes I covet okay
audio Wade was here this week and we did
a show I think it was yesterday an audio
Wade has been really stepping up audio
Wade and and Gibby here they've been
helping to produce a little bit more
I've made my life a lot easier and I
think you analogy came in yesterday and
I saw you get very tired and I was like
oh I can see that face that's the dip
and he was a little wiped out yeah and I
realized right away that a little part
of me was kind of going like oh man okay
I need to take something off his plate
but then a part of me was going like hey
imagine having to host this because that
is something that and sometimes I covet
free time that's true sometimes that
covet free time that people have
sometimes I've looked at people who are
policemen who are firefighters who are
bankers and I go oh man at least I get
the clock out and go home
that's comma dismiss that's wrong
because you know what that may not be
the plan for me that fate I may never be
destined to work eight hours and may be
destined dork ten twelve fifteen hours
my whole life I have no idea but you
know what else I have something that a
lot of people don't have and I should be
grateful for it I get to do a job that
means something to people
not everybody has that and I get to do a
job that means something to me so even
though I don't get the clock out and
yeah we have to work longer hours
because we're doing a show that Samantha
P and Trevor Noah do with less than a
tenth of the staff I shouldn't covet
what other people have because they're
probably coveting something I have or if
they're more of a man than I am a better
man than I am they're not coveting
because they've learned how corrosive it
is and I've had to keep that in check so
my my challenge to you is this what is
it that you covet whether you're a
Bernie bro whether you're a Mogga part
whether you're never Trump er what this
it more importantly not only what do you
covet what decisions do you make on your
day to day life based on your
covetousness it's human nature we all
have it are you voting based on your
covetousness because you want will get a
guy has are you voting for student loan
absorbent are you are you arguing with
your wife because you may be jealous you
but the fact that she doesn't have to
work the same hours that you do or you
may be covetous of I don't know a new
quarter black Garrett might in a new
guitar of someone else or a new Nintendo
Wii something gay hey my point is like a
switch the switch that's right the
switch quicksave I have no problem with
you playing the switch just don't you
you know so well I want you to take a
second here and if you're listening on
audio you're listening to a television
show but I want you there as well there
is bonus which we appreciate oh yes we
do appreciate you and we're doing some
bonus material for those who aren't
subscribed it I guess it's on iTunes
anymore it's Apple Apple yeah wherever
we are and if you're on an Android just
keep it keep the Sam something far from
your face we don't want to explode it
but I want you to write this down pause
it if you have to what decision what do
you covet what decisions are you making
in your day-to-day life based on your
covetous nature because we all have it
write it down and then then what I want
you to do and if you haven't written it
down you're not doing this exercise and
believe me there's when people have you
do these stupid things like write down
your worries and put them on a balloon
that's stupid it doesn't help anybody in
that balloon is it's not gonna go as
high as you think it is you probably
can't afford helium is just gonna some
kids gonna take it and today why is this
person writing down right now my wife is
cheating on me like just don't don't
write down your problems I put on blue
that's my point I know a therapist you
said that one time no longer a therapist
dead so this isn't it write down what it
is that you covet and then I want you to
turn that into proactively gratitude
because for every one thing that you
covet for every one thing that you wish
you had that you don't have guess what
there's a balance with that there's
probably something you have on the flip
side of that coin that somebody else had
that doesn't have that they want in
other words if you're coveting someone's
money you're a man to be a millionaire a
billionaire guess what guarantee you
there's a billionaire somewhere in your
state or the other side of the world
coveting your free time if you're
coveting someone's someone's wife and
that's a common one guarantee you
there's someone else out there right now
who is coveting not having an abusive
wife not saying that person's wife
specifically I definitely think you
should find a good wife a man who finds
a good wife finds what is good let's say
girlfriend
maybe you covered a man's car guess what
there's some guy out there who probably
is coveting not having that kind of an
overhead payment because he he bought a
new car dipped 30 percent when he drove
it off a lot whatever it is that you
covet there is something to be said for
turning it into gratitude or at least
recognizing what it is that you have
that maybe someone else doesn't have and
I not only don't want you do this in
your personal life but we do need to
have this conversation with people out
there because covetousness slothfulness
that's no way to vote in the leader of
the free world folks and that's what
bothers me about Bernie Sanders all
right we'll see you next week there is
no show on Monday so don't covet people
who have a host of the show on Monday
because we're doing a super video we
back Tuesday
[Music]
you